that's Tom Cruise and Kelly McGillis in
the 80s classic Top Gun but Kelly is
mysteriously missing from the sequel Top
Gun maverick separately sin 2020 if
anyone reached out to you where you
asked to appear oh my god no they did
not endorse me I think they would ever
I mean I'm old and I'm fat and I look
age-appropriate for what my age is and
that is not what that whole team is
about and but that to me is it to me I'd
much rather feel absolutely secure in my
skin and who and what I am at my age as
opposed to placing a value on et spoke
exclusively with the actress on Friday
have you seen the new Top Gun trailer do
you plan to see the movie at all I don't
know I mean I guess it depends on what
kind of reviews I guess I'm not racing
to the theater and I'm not racing away
from the theater to see it I mean it's
just not it's not on my little list of
things that I would like to get done I
have a phobia about not working I get I
I love to work and I think that's the
primary force that drives me Kelly has
pulled away from Hollywood in recent
years only appearing in a handful of
projects since 2008 here's what she had
to say about that choice was it just a
time in your life where you were ready
for something new was kind of talk to me
about that honestly I got sober I was on
a journey to figure out who the hell I
was and it was very challenging for me
to have any kind of sense of self or
self identity or real self worth other
than what I did for a living
and it just it didn't become a priority
what became the priority initial
I was raising my girls and being the
best sober parent I could be you know I
think just my priorities and life
changed it wasn't like a major decision
that I made this to leave it was just
that other things became more important
I love acting I love what I do I love
doing theater I don't know to me to meet
my relationship to other people became
more far more important than my
relationship to fame you can have any
remote sense to turn into et July 26 for
more on Kelly
[Music]